spider-man no way home had some  dangerous stunts like the bridge fight  that saw tom holland flipping around  without wires the apartment fight  between spider-man and green goblin had  the actors breaking through walls and  multiple levels of flooring tom holland  was bloodied and exhausted by the end of  his fight scene with the green goblin in  the finale like i bust my hand up  like my knuckles were bloodied and on  the last day of shooting that fight  scene when jon said cut  uh  willem and i both just collapsed to the  floor  tom and zendaya were no strangers to  dangerous heights during this film you  know she did nearly 50 feet of freefall